India is trying to build what could be
the world's largest facial recognition
system New Delhi says the system could
help fight crime and find missing
children the technology has already been
launched in a few Indian airports police
in New Delhi say they had identified
nearly 3,000 missing children during the
trial period last year
but not everyone's convinced internet
freedom advocates say there's little
information about where and what the
system will be used for our data will be
stored the use of facial recognition
software is common in places like China
but one Russia study has revealed the
technology to be highly inaccurate well
let's get more on this we're joined now
by planet Prakash from Bengaluru in
India he's a fellow at the center for
Internet and Society he's talking to us
in a personal capacity today very good
to have you with us on al-jazeera
so can the Indian government deploy the
system even though there is little
information on where or where it will be
used what the data will be used for and
how storage data storage will be
regulated given the lack of a law who
actually governed this given that there
is a lack of privacy law in India and
there is no law that actually governs
the software that is being used the
facial recognition software to say in
what kinds of cases it may be use what
kinds of databases that may pull from
and so on nothing authorizing the
setting up of such a project it's highly
questionable in my opinion whether it
would be legal if the government goes
ahead with this so could we see this
come in front of the Supreme Court but
you know in the landmark ruling in 2017
on the National biometric identity card
program our dad said that individual
privacy is a fundamental right amid
concerns over data breaches and the
cards you know mandated use for services
could we see the Supreme Court check the
rollout of facial recognition technology
absolutely so right now it is at a stage
where the government has asked has put
out a public tender asking for software
vendors to get back to it and and so far
it hasn't had much success and but on
the other hand if it does actually go
ahead with this
project and given the lack of
accountability mechanisms given the lack
of any checks and balances and given how
India's intelligence agencies aren't
even answerable to Parliament are and to
the people they don't operate in under
any law it's it's very highly likely
that it will be challenged in court and
indeed in 2017 in the different
challenging Supreme Court the Delhi
Police said that only there the accuracy
of the facial recognition system that
they were using was only 1% and that
often mistook little girl children for
boys and so on and so forth I mean if
with an accuracy rate of 1% why is the
government wanting to roll out such
technology I mean the Indian police say
it's needed to bolster we know what is
an incredibly severely under police
country but is this the way to do it so
I don't think it's fundamentally a
question of of usage of technology there
are good uses for technology however
that any kind of users especially those
that mean fringe upon civil liberties of
a facial recognition quite certainly may
need to be highly regulated in fact in
San Francisco usage of facial
recognition by the police departments
actually been banned and so in in
country like India where we have an
absence of privacy laws without very
strict regulation it's just foolish for
the government to go ahead that this
kind of a project because the the the
capacity for abuses superbly high and we
have multiple cases in fact even two
weeks ago in the Bombay High Court
double-space about unlawful phone
interception by the police and in which
the court found that the government had
in fact unlawfully intercepted and so
the amount of unlawful illegal
surveillance in India is known to be
high and in the kind of situation to
bring in even more technology without
providing any safeguards whatsoever for
citizens or indeed any limitations on
how the police or other agencies of the
government may use this on what kinds of
databases they may get information from
for the facial-recognition none of
that's actually put out there in the
tender and no safeguards are provided
and indeed we need a law and that the
absence of proper look to go ahead will
just create the police state Martine
mr. Prakash it is great to get your
expertise on this we really appreciate
your time that is furnished Prakash live
in Bengaluru thank you